it now appears as though George Santos
slash Anthony devolder may have uh lied
about his coveted diagnosis everything
has to be hyperbolic with Santos and he
once claimed to be one of the first
people in the United States to be
diagnosed with covid-19 uh which is like
what this is the Hallmark of
pathological Liars where they lie about
things no one really cares about like
someone had to be one of the first
people diagnosed with covet doesn't
really matter who it was but he had to
claim he was one of those people a
Business Insider reports George Santos
claimed to be one of the first people in
the U.S diagnosed with cobit that looks
to be bogus too
George Santos's latest dubious claim
involves a covet diagnosis from 2020.
the timeline of testing positive and
getting sick differs in various
retellings of the story his descriptions
of the severity of his illness have also
changed over time
the first case of covet in New York was
confirmed on March 1st 2020. and Santo
said in a conservative podcast he had
symptoms of covet just a week later
around March 8th 9th unfortunately on
the 9th of March I became symptomatic
with what we all know very well covid
AKA coronavirus commonly known as the
Chinese flu on the 11th I ended up in
the hospital really bad fever body aches
he said he was in a hospital in Queens
he was there by ambulance spent five
hours in isolation had fever he was
hallucinating and ultimately tested
positive on March 14th and subsequently
negative on March 26th but when he later
talked about the story he had a
different story both in terms of the
severity and the timeline on the day
Santos says he got a positive test he
was bedridden with a fever his campaign
put out a press release including a
quote for him from him and didn't
mention that he was sick it's kind of
weird to put out a statement about covid
on a day on which you're positive and
you're so sick you can't leave your bed
and you don't mention you have it four
days later he was on Fox Business and he
seemed completely fine
very weird and meanwhile in a September
2020 interview with the Long Island
Outlet the island now he says the
hospital said oh just take some Advil or
Aleve
and March 5th 2021 he said on Twitter it
was his anniversary of going to the
hospital for covid but that lines up
with a completely different date
so he lied about his employment history
he lied about his educational history he
lied about his athletic Acumen he lied
about being Jewish from a family of
Holocaust Survivors it appears as though
he also lied about the covid-19 timeline
really wacky and bizarre stuff I hope
they do destroy his career because he
deserves to have it destroyed now I'm
not saying he shouldn't work and he
should starve okay he should have his
career in the position that he obtained
based on lying about everything
destroyed that career he can go back and
you know if he thinks that he's a
finance guy even though those were lies
go go back and work in finance or you
know get some job somewhere else but the
job he got on the basis of the lies he
should lose and let's hope that that
happens one of our sponsors today is
zipix nicotine toothpicks zipix brings
you a convenient alternative to smoking
and vaping and The Vape clouds the
ashtrays the thing in your lip that
people can see I've seen that around
this is an easier and less messy way to
curb the cravings and you can use zipx
just about anywhere zipx is available in
six flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipix has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered there customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipix toothpicks you can
only get zipx online go to zipx
toothpicks.com and get 10 off with the
code Pacman the link is down below